suis désolé de vous le dire mais olivier
ferrand honnêtement on arrive à discuter
avec bruno le maire sans aucun problème
griset aucun problème olivier ferrand
qu'est ce qui se passe qu'est ce qui se
fait attendre et rester focalisé
l'énervé qu'est ce qui semble suis pas
énervé ça me gonfle c'est dans quinze
jours a dit ensuite ressemble au débat
politique avec les uns les autres
génial mais en fait il ya un moment
donné je suis désolé la précision vous
intéresse pas et donnez vous intéresse
pas ce que vous voulez vous avez les
problèmes d'enfants s'étaient conte de
fées raconter les vous voulez les uns
vous dit absolument c'est évident c'est
tellement évident qu effectivement les
pays qui l'ont connu massivement aussi
quelques soucis avec ça je finis le 59
baguette magique n'existe pas premier
élément
deuxième élément je m'évertue essayer de
vous expliquer qu'on est en train de me
donner les chiffres doré à ce que
personne n'a été foutu jusqu'ici le de
démonter et de démentir via mais tout le
monde s'en fout eh bien écoutez récit
dans vos débats politiques et pendant ce
temps là mais ce que j'essaye de vous
dire c'est qu'effectivement on a
aujourd'hui je cherche à comprendre
comment en ayant en tout 19 mai lit
entre les soins intensifs les soins
continus et la réanimation
on est capable de m'expliquer qu'on a
cinq mille personnes aujourd'hui en
réanimation et que les hôpitaux sont
full premiers éléments vous êtes
deuxième question je suis en terminale
j'ai suffisamment à temps chez vous pour
pouvoir parler deuxième caisse deuxième
question que je me pose est que les
français se posent
je trouve tout à fait curieux qu'on ait
une augmentation subite des réanimations
particulièrement l'ap-hp en ile de
france alors que l'on nous explique pas
le soin de donner c'est le premier bois
attendez attendez j'ai à prétention
effectivement ici je peux faire des
choses relativement sérieux ces données
avec des données sources étaient portés
débouchés restent hésitants le débat
politique table et je pense que c'est
parce que vous il a d'abord aidé car je
cherche à comprendre c'est fait je
cherche à comprendre comment est-ce que
ayant des patients en soins sont s'ils
cherchent à quai en soins continus
même pas vrai bien effectivement mais on
se retrouve avec on nous dit 5000 bercy
scénario du mode yves fabbri n'a pas
brillé mais ça sert à rien je vais
m'arranger en pleine me 4 a marre alors
fabrice jeannet en gironde mais attendez
excusez-moi minutes je suis en train de
parler deux choses extrêmement sérieuses
auxquelles personne n'a répondu et 100 m
ce centre est de dire que les chiffres
avant avant février 2020 ce qu'on
appelait la réanimation correspondent à
une définition donnée par la direction
générale de la santé
cette définition a changé à la faveur du
covin je vous écoute et mais rentrons
pas dans une discussion chimiques mais
enfin monsieur seven c'est pas vrai ce
que je vous dis écoutez ci s'élèverait à
12 ans important je n'ai ainsi pas peur
sert à rien d importation son fouquet je
cherche à défendre
pourquoi l on disait penser que les
chiffres sont bidonnés ne le pense
crassier jeu mais je m'interroge
jonglage de charlie
s'est interrogé sur le phénomène que ces
patients admission d de france tout le
monde tout le monde dont la droite s'est
interrogé dans moi même je me suis
interrogé et effectivement il ya une
admission massif de patients en
réanimation en réanimation intensive les
deux les deux il ya potentiellement eu
certains patients qui ont été transférés
de soins intensifs vers la réanimation
pour des raisons tout à fait explique
alors c'est qu'ils pouvaient stopper les
au petit feu ça c'est une raison qui m'a
été donnée mais je comprends tu poses la
question sur ce sujet là et c'est pas
totalement aberrant jujurieux qui
rameute moi je reviens sur 1,9 fois
monsieur taureau qui dit on aurait dû
avoir les doses plutôt premier point
là-dessus déjà les seuls pays qu'on
vaccine émettre sur un ton plein
d'autres c'est les pays qui ont payé et
qu'on produit le vaccin c'est à dire la
grande bretagne et les etats unis et
l'israël 5
je suis complètement à partir mais
j'avoue et pas dans les mines il fallait
pas mais je ne sais pas d'où ça sur toi
mais justin utile c'est qu'on n'aurait
pas pu avoir plus de dos tout simplement
parce qu a pas de pays européens dans
l'europe qu'à trouver un vaccin et il a
produit donc c'était pas possible donc
après c'est de la géopolitique
effectivement les anglais se favorise au
avec leurs vaccins eux les américains se
favoris eux avec leurs vaccins arn
on comprend tout à faire la tête était
un peu naïf de penser qu'il suffit de
passer des commandes et qu'on n'oserait
pas rigide deuxième chose pourquoi on a
pas confiné plutôt déjà c'était
absolument pas écrit qu'elle est
forcément avoir une remontée qui est
expliquée par le comportement des gens
la preuve en est c'est que ça ne remonte
pas dans tous les départements de la
france ça ne remonte pas dans tous les
départements de la france ça remonte
dans certains départements et à chaque
fois il ya une cause qui est bien
précises à dunkerque à nice ou dans les
départements de l'est de l'île de france
donc comment vous pouviez prévoir que
ces comportements allait être
enregistrée en mars alors que vous étiez
en janvier justement juste on va juste
passé à touche pas à mon poste ça
continue c'est parti et jouvet
juste pour résumé fabrice di vizio vous
êtes en train de dire que tout ça a été
manipulée qu'on a manipulé j entrais non
moi je n'affirme rien laure baqué
souvient de me traiter de complotiste
c'est trop facile
non mais hier quand on a pas les risques
on vous dit alors ah mais ce que je dis
non c'est non je dois pas ce que je dis
moi ce que je questionne dire c'est tout
j'interroge n'avait pas l'air ce que
vous avez des réponses oui justement que
les ai pas les réponses comment
j'explique que l'on m'explique
aujourd'hui qu'à 46 % des patients qui
sont en réanimation qui sont en réalité
en unité de soins intensifs et l'intérêt
de ce mode hip hop l'intérêt de ce que
je dis que peut s'il y en a un nom au
coeur s'il y en a un c'est vous ment sur
les chiffres ou si on a une
approximation sur les chiffres ça compte
quand même non non vous savez que c'est
maintenant on explique que les leaders
et à son foule pressée sauf que c'est
ben oui on est bon si ça mais monsieur
c'est pas parce que c'est pas parce que
excusez moi c'est pas parce que ça vous
intéresse pas vous prendre pour le
centre du monde vous affairez excusez
moi j'ai un monsieur si tu veux tu as tu
eu les consignes on vient en régie
excusez moi monsieur ramener jeux 3d
numéro du sérieux
c'est la réflexion je crois que vous
avez un problème monsieur oui j'ai un
problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui notre
écosystème il est profondément
bouleversé et vous faites la diarrhée
verbale et kaboré c'est que
juridiquement vous vous pourrez d'aidé
mais qui sont bord du gouffre des
entreprises qui n'ont plus de fonds et
qui ont pu tune et qui ont des trous
dans la raquette et vous les emmenez sur
des procédures qui dure dix comme ça
sipa 2006 à bristol attaquer nos mines m
je dénonce croyez moi vous croyez que
vous croyez je vais m'abaisser à un
niveau comme ça c'est ma carrière c'est
la galère je termine je termine urgences
observé la hausse inattendue royer qui
avec l'acteur couvert qui est la mienne
enfin m je ne partais pas non